in this video we'll talk about hyper IGM
syndrome this is a high yield topic for
USMLE part 1.
hyperigm syndrome is one type of tea and
B cell disorders
in this particular syndrome there is
over representation of IGM in a
patient's serum it's also known as
x-linked hyperigm syndrome and in this
particular condition the males are
affected because males have only one
chromosome X so there is no extra
chromosome X to counterbalance this in
female mostly they are carriers
now in hyper IGM patient there is an
over representation of IGM antibody in
the serum but the question is why there
is more IGM
so we have to understand that and
understand the biology behind the hyper
IGM syndrome so let's begin
this is a B cell b-cell interacts with
the T Cell via the T Cell receptor the
first interaction the T cell and mhc2
interaction give rise to Signal one for
Activation and cd40 and cd40 ligand
interaction give rise to second signal
for Activation in case of hyper IGM
syndrome there are genetic defects which
lead to a faulty cd40 ligand on T cell
moral of the story B Cell Activation is
not proper that lead to several problems
that prevents the isotype switching so
by default IGM antibody gets produced
and other subtypes or isotypes are not
produced we'll come back to it in
details but this kind of situation leads
to
clinical situations like severe pyogenic
infections in early life opportunity
opportunistic infection from
pneumocystis cryptosporidium and CMV
so let us try to understand this in bit
more detail
so there are two types of B Cell
Activation I have a different video on B
Cell Activation but anyway
so in the stronger B Cell Activation
happens when the T Cell activates the B
cell and that's why there are two
signals which are required which we have
discussed early
so the signal 2 cannot be transmitted
when Siri 40 ligand is defective
in normal cases the cd40 and cd40 ligand
interaction give rise to second signal
which leads to a activation of B cell
but what happens when the B cell is
activated but before that let me tell
you
there could be also cross-linked antigen
that can activate B cells but that
activation is not very strong not enough
to switch isotypes
so there are bacterial components like
flagellin LPS all of these can activate
B cell independent of the T cell
B T Cell dependent or independent
activation of B cell b cell would
eventually proliferate
and increase their number
now naive B cell once actually produce
membrane bound IGM and igd these are the
predominant or by default antibodies
which are present in a naive B cell
eventually the naive B cell encounter
the T cell and they interact with each
other they become activated after that B
cell kind of differentiate into plasma
cell plasma cell can produce different
types of potential antibody for example
IGG
but producing IGG from the default state
of IGM requires ISO type switching I
have a different video on ISO type
switching link is in the description and
the I button this ISO type switching is
messed up in hyper IGM syndrome why it
is messed up because there is a
defective cd40 ligand that's why the B
Cell Activation is not strong enough to
evoke the class switching response once
class switching does not happen by
default more and more IGM is produced
and that is why the patient serum has
over representation of IGM antibodies
let's talk about some of the clinical
symptoms
clinical symptoms might include
sinusitis ear infection
and also there could be chances of
diarrhea and there are problems with
diet and overall physiology
some patients not all displays reduction
in neutrophil levels
and nobody knows the reason yet
but anyway the affected individual can
also develop or are in higher risk of
developing
autoimmune disorders
anyway I hope this video was useful if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe follow me on Facebook and
Instagram for getting more notes
you can support my channel using super
thanks and share this channel link with
your friends see you in next video